it's the beginning of October 2019 so
it's time for another monthly update
video I'm going to talk about what went
on in the month of September and what
we've got coming up this very very
packed month of October you might have
missed some things from September and
you definitely don't want to miss the
things from October I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
and two of the big things this month
have to do with stoicism so big thing
number one stoic week is happening not
just here in Milwaukee but all around
the world you can you know go to modern
stoicism slash stoicism today get all
the details about that it begins on a
Monday ends on a Sunday and big thing
number two in the middle of that on
October 12th we'll be having a stoic on
X event here in Milwaukee it's sort of
like the big stoic on just a little
smaller in scale we we actually are
doing one of the larger stoic on X's and
so that's really cool and tomorrow right
after this video airs I'm going to be
taking part in a conversation that I was
invited to at the Boswell book company
here in Milwaukee with author Veronica
Roth if you know the divergent series
she's the author of that she's got a new
book out and I was the person invited to
join in the conversation a little bit of
a pleasant surprise but you know it'll
be a lot of fun we've been corresponding
a bit so those are the three things that
we've got that that I really wanted to
put out there right away let's talk
about September now so what went on in
the month of September other than
teaching seven academic classes which is
like more than almost double load of
many academics well I had some public
events and appearances we started off
with a face to face event here in the
speculative fiction series we got to
talk about somebody who I'm a big fan of
Carl Edward magner and his came novels
so that was a lot of fun great
conversation linked to below if you
click the show more you can see the link
for that video I was on the air several
times in local radio stations both times
talking about the upcoming stoical on X
event and stoicism in general so first I
was on WTMJ nights on there there you
know WTMJ night show and then I was
invited to come on the morning show on
River West radio called another morning
and the TMJ nights hasn't come out the
the recording of it yet but you can
click below and see the River West Radio
one we also had our you know Milwaukee
stoic fellowship that I helped host I
did some online events you know my usual
AMA and half-hour Hagel hangouts and
philosophy chat and I premiered a video
on self-directed study of st. Anselm of
Canterbury and then you know answered
questions and and engaged in discussion
and the chat as people are watching it
for the first time I didn't you know I
mentioned I have been teaching an awful
lot that's that's quite a bit of work
and there's course development to do as
well I have also been exercising pretty
regularly you know get had a few days
where I was sick and and couldn't get in
the workout and the way my schedule is
if I can't get in the workout then it
ain't happening at their time did quite
a bit of tutorial work I've had a couple
new clients join some philosophical
counselling and of course this is an
incredibly busy time of year for me as
the editor of Stoicism today so I was
doing quite a bit of work with them I
also was on some some podcast things I
went on the Sunday stoical podcast that
came out quite recently link is below
again
the Enter the Void podcast episode that
I was in aired as well and we recorded
but it hasn't come out yet a podcast
episode with the post-structuralist tent
revival talking about thumos and anger
and ancient philosophy so that's going
to be a lot of fun when it comes out did
some video work as I always do shot a
lot of Aquinas videos and released all
of those I shot some work on Seneca and
it's some new stuff to the repertoire
for that so I'm working on pre-socratics
Parmenides and zeno I did get one Hegel
video done and released and of course
the videos from the events so September
was quite a busy month and you know I
didn't get as much done as I would have
liked but I did in fact get quite a bit
done October may in fact be my busiest
month of the year all told as we go
through the events you'll see why that's
the case
I will mention that I'm of course still
teaching seven classes and trying to
work out and eat healthy we changed our
diet as well do still doing a lot of
tutorial sessions philosophical
counseling some consulting and there's a
ton of work to do for stoicism today
this month because of international
stoic week so in October tomorrow
October 2nd if you're here in Milwaukee
you want to go to Boswell bookstore
because I will be there talking with
Veronica Roth I was invited just to have
a conversation with her to be a second
person up on stage maybe I'm sort of the
equivalent of a color commentator not
quite sure I've got to shoot some some
possible questions over to her quite
soon had some correspondents already and
it looks like it's gonna be a great
conversation on the that's at 7 p.m. at
Boswell book store on the 5th at 12 p.m.
I'll be having my online AMA session for
the month I'm trying to do those first
Saturdays of the month so that's the
time for that on the 10th at 7 p.m.
Brookfield Public Library I will be
doing the next worlds of speculative
fiction series event and that is on
Aldous Huxley and his utopia is and
dystopian so we're not just gonna talk
about brave new world we're also gonna
talk about the island and some other
things probably talk about is his
perennial philosophy as well we'll see
what we get into with that then the
biggest event is on the 12th the stoic
on X conference that we have scheduled
here in Milwaukee at this point in time
we still do have some tickets but
they're actually going quite fast it's a
free event but you do have to have a
ticket because we're catering a lunch
and we've only got so much room in the
place got three great talks in the
morning and then we're gonna do some
lightning round talks and have a nice
lunch together and then Andy and I are
gonna give the the workshop that we were
both going to give I gave it for both of
us at the last stoic on in London on the
stoic hearts partnered relationships so
that should be quite good as well
then we kind of fast forward a bit to
much later in the month on the 23rd and
at 5:00 p.m. will have our Hegel Q&A and
discussion session that's for anybody
who wants to talk about Hegel or German
idealism or even philosophy in general
you just show up and we'll
videoconference on the 26th at 12:00
p.m. we'll be doing a video premiere for
another one of these self directed study
videos this one is going to be about
early Christian philosophy so we'll be
talking about you know thinkers like
Justin Martyr and locked-on seus and
John Cassian and clement of alexandria
all these really cool authors that you
might not even have heard
and I'll be I'll be talking about them
and how you can productively study their
works also on the 26th at 3:00 p.m.
we'll have our philosophy chat for
patreon supporters that's that's a perk
that we we give to patreon supporters
for their their you know generous
support and then finally on the 31st
Halloween 6:00 p.m. we have our
Milwaukee stoic fellowship and we will
have gone through stoic week together
and we'll talk about the results of that
in that meeting and a little bit of
Marcus Aurelius as well so that should
be quite fun what else is going on
during the month like I mentioned I'm
teaching a lot and still doing a lot of
work and trying to exercise pretty
regularly it's gonna be a little bit
tough these first two weeks as we lead
up to all the Stoics stuff but I'm sure
I'll get some some non physical exercise
in there as well could be shooting a lot
of video this month I released some
Augustine video already to my patreon
supporters I'll be releasing those to
the general public over the course of
this month I'm also shooting a lot of
new Descartes video on the meditations
some video on David Hume and I'll be of
course you know having the event videos
and the video premiere on self-directed
study of early Christian philosophy I'm
gonna shoot some more half-hour Hegel
videos and hopefully I'll get to some
book reviews this month we'll see if
that happens or not but you know I'm
kind of hoping for it because I really
do have a lot of books that need to get
get out there the the month wants the
stoic weak and stoic on is over I think
we'll start to become a little bit
easier and hopefully the rest of the
year will ease up as well
oh I will say one other thing too I'm
already getting scheduled for classes in
the spring with some of the local
colleges that I work for so I know I'll
be teaching business ethics comes
and probably be teaching ethics for
artists and designers and intro to
humanities and we'll see what else comes
my way I'm pretty confident I'll also be
teaching some online classes but I'm not
going to do the the crazy class load
that I have this semester it'll almost
be like going on vacation to do a
full-time class load rather than that so
all of that scope coming up I'm hoping
to get some podcast work done as well
I'm going on a few other podcasts once
again one stoical week is over
and I can take a little bit of a
breather so that's what's going on in
October really packed month if you hear
in the Milwaukee area you definitely
want to come to the events you know the
Veronica Roth conversation at Boswell
books stoical on X at the Central
Library and the annals Huxley talked
just before it at the Brookfield public
library if you're interested in stoicism
come out to the stoic fellowship we meet
at the Shorewood Public Library in the
conference room every month last
Thursday of the month so hope all of you
have a great month ahead and there's not
much else to say other than that
you